hello there reject nation i'm greg john
is
is my name today we're gonna watch
superman and lois
episode six i'm doing my superman
cadence today
every superman has a very specific
delivery
very straightforward american spirit
yeah so american
this episode's called broken trust trust
is the foundation of any good civilian
and hero in america
and the world ladies and gentlemen i'd
appreciate it very much so if you would
go ahead and hit that like button
also subscribe click that notification
bell to get notified
whenever our next superman and lowest
reaction is up over at patreon
that's where you'll find our full-length
reaction watchalongs that's where you
sync up with the timecode
a fact that some people seem to forget
when they pledge to our patreon page
which i've clearly stated at the
beginning of a video at our patreon
we cover many many shows and over there
you get the option for both reaction
highlights and watch along included
lastly
thank you to pratham jindal for editing
these reaction highlights for us
i don't know what we do without you
let's watch superman oh that's lex
luthor
nice yeah that's a great impression hey
superman
we got kryptonite chase you round
[Music]
picking up moments later a month later
i don't know what come on tag
i don't know what you're talking about
liar
ever since then it's okay john you know
just reacting
superman i'm not gonna hurt you
nipple chills
looks like you're it tag
no
wow
wow
a train conductor reacted fairly normal
to the yeah
superman sleeping my ass again that's
the fifth time this week
another week i forgot how good this show
looked this guy's such a dick
hey hey language language
yeah you okay
ah yeah it's just a headache jordan
how would you feel about sitting out
tomorrow's game why
because it's because of the things this
will be affected by what happens it's
really important to me
you promise you're 100 healthy yeah
totally good to go totally good to go
except this headache then after school
you're gonna prove it this is proof my
suspicions were correct
this is proof jordan's okay play ball
yeah thank you very much yeah
just like i thought he would well the
smallville team needs a strong leader
and i'd like to fill that role with you
lana
[Music]
i'm grateful i i when you see your new
starting salary
you'll say yes kyle check if you still
have balls
oh kyle it's okay he's ready to give him
over to morgan edge
he thinks i'm made of glass
[Music]
he's got our beef he's good to play
what the hell was that okay that is not
that was not a panic attack
it's my head you need to tell dad you
might need to go to the fortress to
figure out what's wrong we can't
tell that jordan you need to tell him
look if we tell daddy won't let me play
football tomorrow jordan
john let me have this those metropolis
guys
woodrum carter campana they made my life
hell let me shut them up
let me incinerate them hey i'm on
jordan's side
i don't care how to control youth
murder those kids go ahead let's start
with this
oh dope am i somehow supposed to crack
this in half
nope just punch it don't any gloves or
something
look at the dents
thanks dad yep yep okay no i thought
we'd try going on instinct
i felt
[Laughter]
[Music]
imagine this big log this cutter's face
throws the log into outer space
now cool
yes yes that's what i'm talking about
yes sir
the hell forget
[Music]
i'll do an instagram video yes spotted
in metropolis
not great metropolis all right that's
where the boys football game is tomorrow
you stay with the boys i'll have my guys
on site
hey shortstack you see that linebacker
55 out there he's been killing us all
day
now look i want you to go in there and
you knock him on his backside you got
that
let's go let's
stick your ass go just like grade school
laser him jordan come on jojo
[Music]
activate your stand jojo
[Music]
looks like the crow's quarterback is
hurt
oh jordan pissed
like that cutter hey
jordan get over here
[Music]
rain it in or you're done you're just
making a block that's not what i'm
talking about
and you know it you understand me yeah
good
go sit down how dare clark hold him back
yeah
let him unload on that kid
what are you doing here marcus still
open to sharing the byline i'm
smoldering on the front of the market
that hands on a couple inspector badges
they are working round the clock to get
those minds ready
right now the tunnels are packed with
inspectors
security is stretched in a lone black
guy might look suspicious but
huh the two of us together it'll seem
more legit so
are you in need my white lady shield wow
what's that interracial couple doing
yeah what are they doing here
not in the head town not at small
okay that's the pizza guy get up do you
think it's tag or the pizza guy
it's tag as the pizza guy
time hey sarah the truth is
complicated just stick up for people
oh the cameraman shakes whoa
ow oh that's bad no bueno
i love that subtle move with the camera
so subtle
what was that
[Applause]
broken out ah i don't think i've ever
seen it
no no no no no no no no
no no no
you dicks
oh man that was crazy
thank god clark decided to coach oh
damn that was crazy did you get me
dessert
oh sweets it's way past your bedtime
where is your sister i think she's in
her room
yeah come here
no i'm gonna check the security cam
footage
what jordan he needs to know look the
first time that he had one of these
episodes or whatever uh it mean it
stopped it seemed fine
the first time i had a migraine at
school it wasn't a big deal
and you didn't tell me and you taught me
from playing the game yeah
and i would have been right so i'm just
supposed to be punished for something
that isn't my fault
this was my shot dad i know and i get it
okay i know what it's like to be picked
on
yeah but you get to grow up and you get
to be superman
who am i oh poor guy too
hey lana sorry can i can i call you back
clark real quick did sarah come to the
game
no i didn't see her what's that that
harris kid oh my god yeah it is
stay here everything okay stay here are
you sure about this
no point playing your cautious now right
got my hands on some schematics
the show's so good
tag what the hell where are we it's okay
so a high-tech gadget guy works for
luther core the top
tech company in the world only to quit
and pursue
a career in journalism feels like i
should be focusing my story
on you she's so good what is that
xk hey known as x kryptonite
there's your story miss lane too bad no
one's going to read it
[Music]
hey people will read that story
absolutely
he's a page-turner
it's good that's good you're good all
right yeah let's go
we're going where to pay some millennial
to get us a few sixers so we can
celebrate properly
that'd be sad guys but honestly my pop
said we got to stay here so it's not
like we're going clubbing liquor store's
just up the street
all right you know what we want a big
game come on let's go
come on yeah you love alcohol come on
[Music]
nice
[Music]
i hope they don't bump it to the other
[Music]
i think they're going to bump into the
dorky kid since forever cried if he was
breathed on
what now you're like the best guy on the
football team
you uh juiciness or something there jojo
is that what's going on you juicing jojo
huh break his face
[Laughter]
no no way i will make sure that you are
safe and that you get the answers that
you want but right now we need to leave
the dod is coming for you i need you to
trust me
stand down
[Applause]
you can't do this
no did jonathan stop
his punch yeah
oh no he broke his wrist i thought he
had powers for a second
they got kryptonite bullets
you pieces of [ __ ]
murder them clark
damn oh you feel betrayed
oh stand
[Laughter]
just come back so strong you're not
gonna be alone anymore okay
i promise i'm adopting you
[Laughter]
you know i thought about all the ways
you might try to stop that boy
never occurred to me you would actually
use live rounds let alone once fitted
with kryptonite
hey are we gonna talk about what
happened back there you saw what i saw
that's your story you are armed to the
teeth with the kind of weapons that
would put you high on the fbi's most
wanted list
and the security badge i sent a photo to
a friend of mine and she said it's one
of the best forgeries she has ever seen
so why don't you tell me who you really
are and why you are in small though
cause i don't buy that you came to write
a story
i can't tell you why i'm really here but
i can promise you like you
i am trying to prevent something bad
from happening yeah i got to say it to
someone just one time
one time i you know i never
meant okay but you did you you did
jordan you you
got emotional and then and now i have a
broke ass arm and i'm probably never
going to play quarterback again so
thanks
just keep getting the short head here
the
[Laughter]
all the dude tries to do is the right
thing i told you
your powers come with responsibility and
i need you to get that
things are different now yeah i know i
know they're different
do you because you made a big point at
the hotel saying you're different from
me
but you're not well made you want to use
your powers the way you did tonight
i have those feelings too
you do yes but i keep them in check
otherwise i risk losing the trust of the
very people i've sworn to protect
20 years later every time i use my
powers that trust
is tested every time
the thing about trust jordan once you
break it takes a lot longer to heal than
a wrist
oh it's late damn he is so good
the full package man
such a great casting call probably not
the best time to tell you i almost got
killed tonight
[Laughter]
leslie lahr came after us turns out she
has powers too
she tried to heal i scared it
or can now win lois
what aren't you telling me i haven't put
it all together yet
he's up to something i just don't know
exactly what
i could help you figure out if in fact
you need someone on the inside and
kyle's okay with this
golly i got no [ __ ] she had heard any of
this conversation
oh boy
i don't know how to fix this i heard
john i can still hear his phone snapping
oh
come here kid
[Music]
jordan
[Music]
don't you [ __ ] hatch i would no no
what's gonna happen is it damn it
now i gotta tune in next week
i gotta find out what happened
[Music]
oh boy i missed this
like a great great this is like
good was it this good before like her
level superman storytelling i remembered
it being great but
like why does it like feel so much
greater
maybe maybe distance makes the heart
grow fonder or maybe they took some time
in that month off to be like let's
really make this great
and also like not hopping between other
superhero shows as much
too yeah you know like i don't know
i was like i could sit here for another
like two hours if i want to do it
absolutely that was really good hell
yeah
just drag these mics over here because
it's the talking portion of the video
so yeah okay
um wow processing
should have made notes that's not our
style so now we like to dome it we're
gonna dome it today
i i really don't remember it being
this like intense it's so intense yeah
they really know how to ramp up the
tension you know what makes this show so
good is they they really keep the family
drama uh the the core
of all of it and i just love like the
way it all
escalated so out of control like when
they were cutting between
several events by the end of the episode
when you have
clark at the school or in the hotel room
or even at the
even at the football game you're dealing
with that lois
and lex going into the mines
um and then there was another thing that
was the third thing though oh yeah then
the tag
and clark tagging clark but tagging
sarah
uh the kidnapping situation there all
these different
puzzle pieces just moving together and
just eat the mystery the intensity all
ramping up i just thought it was so well
executed
i mean started off with just like both
superman and lois you know clark and
lois they're so damn good they're both
great like they're they're off doing
their own thing uh
so much in this episode but whenever you
check in with them like they
they don't need to be in this like lois
does not need to be in the same room as
clark to stand out
and then when they're together it just
shines like i love that scene at the
dinner table when
like uh you know the clark is giving his
speech
saying how you know jordan i know how
you feel believe me i do
i've had to learn to earn people's trust
i was judged
heavily when i first started doing this
i had to understand that people
feared me because of what my
capabilities are and i have to really
work to regain trust
all the time so i understand how you
feel and then he checks it with lois and
like how was your day
the reactions that he get gets from it
like finding out that woman has super
powers is just like defeated just like
why is everything like he's just like
another he's the perfect balance of just
a relatable
guy yeah and something greater than a
regular guy
yeah he's superman you know and i i love
his portrayal it is pitch perfect uh
tyler
hoakland or whatever how you say his
name hatchling hecklin i think
didn't even come close tyler heckland uh
so
so impressive wildly impressive man um
yeah john say some stuff before i start
talking about every
single thing no yeah it is totally
impressive partly because
two you know whenever you're cutting to
just a clark based storyline or a lowest
base storyline you're in
or at least i am engrossed no matter
where we are i'm never sitting here
going can we get back to this thing
please
and i like that yeah they have done such
a good job of
you know infusing everything into the
family drama aspect it doesn't
intervene to the point that it feels
annoying which
you know other shows it can but it it
sort of does it in a way that reminds
you
about both the gray areas of life and
also like what
everything is for like you know you come
home at the end of the day to your
family no matter if you're out fighting
crime or you're out trying to play a
football game so like what is
everything we're here doing for it's for
you know
living life and having the betterment of
our family and our community and stuff
like that
and yet there is so much struggle
you know standing in the way of that and
i thought that this episode i feel like
maybe one thing that contributed to just
the amount of
intensity this one especially has is
like looking back i can't remember
structurally exactly
but this one seemed a bit unique because
you did have these like
three crescendos sort of happening at
the same
time you know with clark intervening on
tag
jordan about to go off on the guy from
metropolis and then
uh lex and lois as well and you have all
these things
kind of reaching ahead simultaneously in
a way that felt very
natural and again very intense yeah and
there wasn't any
like major they had this opening
sequence or hunting down tag or trying
to rescue him
if anything and then the whole train
sequence which is like a cool cgi fast
thing
but to me like the in terms of action
it's pretty
limited in terms of what they did
however like that moment when when
superman gets
shot and the kryptonite bullets land in
him
and the the rage that is coming out of
him of
just like you [ __ ] oh how could
you do
how much i've cooperated really guys
are you serious i'm trying to i'm the
only one who's actually trying to help
this poor kid because tag is just a kid
you know like even though you start this
episode where he's like
rageful he's ultimately just scared he's
he's a kid he's terrified he doesn't
know what the hell is happening to him
yeah and for clark it's like i'm here to
help you guys and him yeah
you guys are not working you guys are
making everything worse it was just such
a badass moment on top of that too like
where he looks up the lasers are in him
he's got the
in that one shot on the left side of him
you got those three little kryptonite
um shrapnel left off into his um like
chest plate
oh so good yeah when he like zooms up to
the one guy
yeah the dude's like yeah no i got it
superman i'm sorry
i didn't mean it well they know how to
make everything feel
gripping and the they keep the emotional
stakes so so
strong like right when lana is talking
with
lois and is saying okay i'm going to
help here like well don't tell kyle
yeah jeez he could be listening right
now that gets me on edge
like no pun intended yeah that puts me
on edge i'm like oh no
don't tell kyle we know how much he
loves that morgan yeah don't tell him
but even at the football game they do a
great job at
really throwing the audience into the
gray because you know how much we
objected against jordan playing
football and now they've got me to the
point where jordan i'm like man this
kid's getting me all emotional now like
yeah it's like he's human he makes
mistakes
it's it's funny how much i've like
shifted with his character
because he just makes mistakes you know
like i don't blame him for any of the
choices that he's making to be honest
like of course you can be logical on the
outside perspective and be like
dude you got to tell your dad what the
hell is going on with you before you
start
going playing football when you got some
weird [ __ ] going on with your brain like
yeah you should mention that at the same
time i i really get what he wants to
play like i'm super invested in
what he's playing football like when
he's at the game i have both feelings
i'm like
yeah jacked him up but don't go too
and the further this plotline has
progressed with him yeah the more i feel
like the nuances have come to life
and you do see what the struggle is
because i loved the beat this episode
when clark is confronting him later on
in the kitchen and he says you know
like i know all these feelings that
you're feeling and not even just because
of what we saw in this episode but yeah
it is that thing of like oh god you
always
want the next generation or your kid or
whoever to learn
from your mistakes and so seldom of the
time do people actually do that
and so it is this heart-wrenching thing
of like man jordan you're really
flirting a dangerous line here and yet
i'm sure clark probably did similar
things when he was young and
you get that struggle of like man i know
clark just wants to keep him on the
right path because of his own experience
but at the same time jordan
needs to make his own mistakes and how
do you do that when you've got
otherworldly gifts
and abilities well it's it's funny with
jordan is like
jordan is the son of clark and
sarah is this is the daughter of lana
and in some ways especially with that
ending moment
between sarah and jordan
and like oh you kind of you're kind of
like the smallville story
you know yeah yeah like oh you know
she's onto something she's into you
but you just can't tell her what's
really going on so it is kind of
like replicating or you know recreating
that
that sense that we have with like lana
and clark specifically i'm thinking of
like the tom welling
yeah uh which was a a really good show
for
the five seasons i saw i didn't finish
it don't worry tom willing he's coming
back
that's true he's open to doing something
um but yeah you have that storyline with
them and then what else happens in here
that was great oh yeah
lex and lois what's so
cool about the interplay there is we as
the
i think it's so great they let the
audience in on that because it makes it
so much more gripping when you're
watching their interaction
it's it's playing with something really
subtle because we know it it that have
how on his planet
the love of his life that he lost is
lois lane
and he doesn't do anything in his
dialogue and interacting with her to let
her
know like yo when i look at you i i just
how he protects her looks after her even
when it came down to like they're being
attacked
and he he's instantly yeah he would if
he was alone he would do the same
actions but there's a different nuance
and layer there when he
is intentionally getting out first i'm
protecting her and then even at the end
he like i
you could tell he kind of wants to tell
her yeah absolutely but he can't tell
her you know
i think that's really really powerful
like i
did and then their chemistry together is
good it's nothing on the along the lines
of like hey i want to see them hook up
or something but
i i like their interaction i like i
really feel like this is the most
personality we gotta see of the guy who
plays lex
absolutely and uh i think he's great you
know like ever this is so charming
this episode just fires on all cylinders
and like the the way they're building up
the sam is the general the the dad yeah
i think so um
yeah the way they're playing up with uh
i have imdb pulled up here in case i
forget a name but i think it's sam i'm
gonna assume it's sam just for the sake
of this discussion
yeah general sam land all right
yeah when you have sam here and
the way they're building up the the the
distance and animosity this unspoken
thing that's happening between superman
yeah
between superman and him of just going
like they're they're on the verge of a
blowout between each other
like the last time they were in that
office together there's just so much
tension
and now here they got more tension again
because and they're not even they're not
saying the full truths especially sam
is not speaking the full truth there's a
lot of hidden things there it's awkward
for him
how what a way for supes to find out
about the bullets about the kryptonite
bullets you know
um yeah i think that the drama's really
good
the uh emotions and all layers are
really felt
and yeah they got a great cliffhanger
here this was this was an awesome
episode yeah this was a
seriously an incredible episode and uh
yeah i don't i i i feel like they shot
no i mean they had a little bit of a
break
but but this would have had to have been
well in progress or maybe even done
you know because you know delaying
something like this i mean they're
probably a few episodes
ahead of their schedule at least by
normal tv standards but yeah i mean they
probably had this one ready to go or or
in
progress before they took the break yeah
i mean
it's just it's so s like the show is so
strong it's like it didn't skip a beat
yeah every scene is good
and i mean all the episodes have had
this but this one maybe yeah it is
because of the break or something but
this one
really felt like man they're doing a lot
and yet it doesn't feel overstuffed
nothing feels too slight
it's really impactful it's fun but also
intense like yeah this was
terrific and it's like everything again
that you might want out of a superman
story because you know you get your big
cg spectacle at the top
you get other moments of action that are
more based on sort of the
interference and intervening of powers
you know as they're taking hold of
people and then a bunch of really
fascinating drama and stuff like that
like you know and and seeing
clark and lois just as much as superman
and you know star reporter like it's
perfect well they really managed to make
the stakes feel very
grounded and personal uh and in
every every moment
yeah absolutely it's not about getting
like a big baddie every episode
no and i love that and everything you
can see a perspective too it's like even
with sam you're like man this is an
awkward position for you and yeah like
this isn't a position of distrust you
want to be in with
superman but at the same time you're
like i kind of get where he's coming
from even
if i don't like the way he's handling it
and again like
they give that to kind of everybody the
only character that's kind of a meme is
kyle
but even he at times you know wants it
he would let lana sleep with morgan
he will eventually if it might keep him
working at you yeah
yeah he'll he'll look like a sour puss
about it but he'll let him get away yeah
he'll blame lana for him yeah yeah i was
just trying to get
with morgan by letting you get in good
with morgan
but he's charming he's a charming actor
yeah he's super that's the thing is he
always brings me back
all right guys superman and lois what'd
you guys think of this episode leave
your thoughts down
below damn that is just damn good
television quality
it really is a plus all right look i had
to do this insert here it's gotta do it
on my phone
but it really bugs me that we didn't
even bring this up during the discussion
but jonathan kent the fact that
this episode seemed like it was going to
be the turning point for all the
suffrage this guy has had to go through
i mean he's always getting the short
hand here
and then he finally gets the chance to
play
quarterback and then bam from protect
the brother that he keeps
looking out for his risk it's completely
injured and it was just such a
shattering moment on all levels
all puns intended but dude
um what's gonna happen with this guy
what's gonna happen this guy the actor
does such a great job but the emotional
impact they have with him so good
so sad god damn guys subscribe click
that notification bell you can check us
out on patreon last but not least
look we may be talking about superman
and lois but there's someone who's a
super
woman it's rosa park oh yeah
i don't know how she died i [ __ ] about
so many things in my life
and then yet i see someone like rosa who
has to be a mom work a full-time job i
manage your side hustles doing film
criticism finding time for movies on top
of all that stuff like
how when do you sleep when do you relax
why do you always seem like you got a
positive optimistic head on your
shoulders despite whatever
trouble life throws at you how are you
able to be so many places at once
and then i just throw on a camera and
complain
and then you just seem to not put out
those vibes
maybe you should be more negative rosa
maybe you could go from being super
to being a villain you know troll people
get out there trash a bunch of movies
get yourself off of press list i like
where you're going
the first time when you were clearly
trying to make her out to were you two
places at once dual identity
superman i i i preferred that one all
right
but i don't recognize you with glasses
on it's weird i'm like who are these two
different people
that's okay we're very good we're good
all right
i hope this was the best shout out that
you've ever received
top 20. thank you rosa
you